你的系统直接宕机
因为他只会查
并不会去想
检索不到答案的时候就开始摆烂
而不是尝试啊
去换一种问法
翻一翻上下文
再重试一遍
不要再骗自己了
传统的rap早就已经过时了
2025年是agent的元年
不会agent tic rap的大模型工程师
就像不会写函数的程序员一样
看似在干活
实则已经被时代淘汰了
今天我们就从最基础的rap开始讲起
一步一步带你揭秘啊
它是如何进化成HT和rap的
那为了让大家更通俗的理解edgetic rag
它的实现流程
那么我将围绕以下三个部分的内容
给大家去进行展开
第一个部分也就是传统的rap是如何去实现的
它解决了什么问题
第二个什么是agent tic rag
它到底啊有什么用
那第三个部分也是我们最重要的
如何通过工具的方式去实现htc rap
下面我们先来看一下他们的基本概念啊
什么是传统rag以及什么是agent tic rag
那首先的话就是我们的传统rag
那传统rap的话我们可以把它分成两个部分
第一个部分呢就是文档的切片
然后到向量化再到存储
第二个部分的话是用户的这个问题啊
然后去进行检索
然后拼接我们的prominent提示词
再到我们大模型的生成
那么这个过程啊相信大家都已经非常熟悉了
那么在这里啊
我们快速的把它过一遍啊
第一个部分的话
也就是我们从切片到向量化存储
那它具体呀指的是什么意思啊
那首先的话我们需要有一些自己的文档
那你想要去做知识库
那你肯定有需要的这样的一些数据
那可能包括像PDF啊
像word啊
哎等等
那有了这些文档之后啊
因为它并不能够一次性全部给到咱们的大模型
那里面的文章或者内容可能会有很多
比如说1万个字
2万个字
所以啊我们需要来对这个文档来进行一个切片
那切片之后我们就能够得到一个一个的段落
每一个段落它的长度啊是256个字符
那互相之间啊可能还会有一定的这个重叠
那对于每一个段落
我们需要用一个embedding模型来进行
向量化的这样一个处理
向量化之后啊
我们就能够得到一个固定维度的这个数组
那么这个数组啊我们也叫做向量
有了这个向量之后
我们再把它存储到对应的这个
向量数据库当中来
然后接下来我们就可以来进行检索和操作
检索也比较简单啊
用户的问题拿到之后啊
我们也是用同样的embedding模型转换成向量
然后在向量数据库当中啊
去计算它们的一个相似度的一个分数
比如你的这个向量数据库里面
它可能有十个片段
那么到底哪一个片段和用户的问题
它的相似度是最高的呢
那么最简单的方法就是
我们可以去做两个向量的点击
然后就会得到一个值
那么值最大的
那其实就是我们最相关的这样一个文档
然后我们就可以把它塞到咱们的这个prominent
提示词里面来
那么在这里
我们可能就能够通过这个similarity啊
来进行这样一个啊相似度的这样一个计算
那么传统的rag啊
我们有两个链路啊
其实我们刚才讲过的
那第一个就是从文档的这个切片
然后到向量化存储的这个过程
那我们可以把它叫做离线链路啊
这个离线链路是什么意思呢
那我再做点给大家重点的我们来看一下啊
首先啊你有了对应的这样一些文档之后
那我们就可以通过咱们的embedding模型来进行
向量化
存储到咱们的向量数据库当中来
好
那这是我们的第一步
这个部分啊其实就是一个离线的
因为它和用户啊其实是没有任何关系的
好吧好
那么在线链路的话就是我们刚刚也有提到过的
就是检索
然后拼接咱们的prominent提示词
然后再到我们这个生成
那么我们来具体啊
看一下它到底是怎么去做的啊
那如果一个用户诶他在提出问题之后
那么首先我们要看的是哪里啊
好是这个啊
user query啊
这是我们的用户好
那么用户首先我们会提出咱们的问题
有了这个问题之后啊
那么首先第一步啊
我们就要来对我们这个用户的问题
来进行一个改写
好这个地方可能有同学会问啊
为什么要去做改写了
那么是因为用户的问题在很多时候啊
它并不一定能够符合我们的一个呃
数据库的这样一个需求
所以我们可以对问题啊来进行一些改写
那更适合于咱们的这样一个检索
所以改写完成之后
那么首先我们可以用第一种方式啊
比如说BM25的方式来进行第一次检索
那么我们就能够得到我们对应的
这样的一些相关的片段
比如说document123
那拿到这三个片段之后
接下来我们同样的再用embedding模型
来对我们改写之后的这个query
来做一个向量化
然后再通过这个向量相似度的这个匹配
来从我们的这个向量数据库当中啊
再来做一次检索
那么我们又能够去返回什么
又能够去返回一批这个document
那么拿到两批document之后啊
接下来我们来对它做一个这个合并啊
做完合并之后
我们再来进行一个重排序的一个过程
比如说这个BM25
你能够拿到三个片段
那么我们的向量的相似度也能够拿到三个片段
那么合并之后就是六个片段
我们再对它来做一次重排序啊
从排序之后
我们再把最终的这样一个片段的一个结果
给到咱们这个prompt里面来
那么这里的PROMIA其实也很简单啊
比如我们就可以写什么呢
这个地方啊我们来看一下
我们可以写一个非常简单的啊
比如这地方有一个prompt example
那么比如你说对吧
你是一个专业的助手来
请根据下面的问题和检索回答
这个文档来进行回答
那在这里的这个context对吧
就是我们检索回来的这个document
一到N的这样的一个文档片段啊
那么你可以去自行进行设置啊
比如说这个top10哎
top3top5啊都可以
然后再加上咱们的这个用户的问题啊
这个concession好
那有了这两个内容之后啊
模型就能够根据我们这个PROMETER啊
来进行最终的这样一个回复
这就是传统rap的运行流程
整个过程啊是单向固定啊
并且是一次性的
首先从用户的问题进行检索
然后拼接相关的这个上下文信息啊
给到我们的prompter提词
然后再交给我们的大模型啊
去进行最后的这样一个答案的一个生成
但事实上有的时候啊
我们的第一轮检索
它其实并不能够得到我们想要的内容
所以模型啊他可能想要重新去检索一遍
或者换一种方式去检索
甚至说我们用某一个工具啊
去获取更多的上下文信息之后啊
再来做最终的回复
那么传统的rag是无法去实现的
所以我们就需要用到咱们的啊agent tic rag
那么它到底是什么呢
其实A平
这个rap是对整个流程的一次根本性的升级
那么它允许它是把整个red当中啊
各个环节
比如说query的改写也好啊
包括向量的检索
以及我们这个关键词的搜索等等
全部都封装成可以去调用的这个工具
也就是我们的这个TOS
并且允许啊大模型在生成答案之前
能够去进行自主的决策
多轮调用以及动态的调整
换一句话来讲
agent tic rag它不再是一条直线走到底
而是一个可以循环的智能体行为的闭环
从思考到调用工具到观察结果
然后再思考再行动
直到生成最终的答案
就是agent tec的概念
把检索能力工具化
让模型啊能够通过啊to you to user的方式啊
去循环的去调用这样一些工具
获取到完整的信息之后啊
然后再返回相关的答案
那这就是agent tic rag好
那么它的整个运行流程啊
其实和我们刚才讲的前面的话
基本上是一样的对吧
首先还是用户啊
咱们user
那么它会产生一个query啊
产生一个问题好
那么有了这个问题之后啊
那之前我们可能直接啊就把它向量化
然后去进行这样一个相似度的一个匹配了
但是现在我们会直接把这个query啊
然后交给咱们的大模型
比如说GBT也好
COUD也好
甚至说deep s好
那么交给他干嘛呢
那么由模型自己啊来进行判断
需不需要去调用咱们的工具
那么这个工具啊它可以是我们本地的工具
也可以是MCP server的工具
总之啊调用完成之后
那他会给我们返回一个什么呢
比如说我们这个to results对吧
就返回一个结果
要给到我们这个模型
那模型就可以根据这样一个结果
然后去决定下一步到底是继续的调用工具
还是说根据已有的结果
然后去返回对应的答案
那这就是它整个的一个流程
那么agent tic rag它的一个实现啊
主要是依赖模型
它需要去具备啊以下的三类核心能力
第一类的话就是我们这个PRONUNNING啊
也就是我们这个规划的这样一个
就是规划的能力啊
比如说要规划怎么去做
然后反思结果怎么样
那么这个我们一般的话是体现在咱们这个
long coo t sync的这样一个过程当中啊
也就我们整个推理的这样一个过程当中
然后第二个核心能力啊
就是我们的一个工具调用啊
或者说多agent的协作的这样一个能力
那么这个我们是体现在工具调用的
这个机制里面的
然后第三步也就是我们模型啊
它可以在回答最终的答案之前
能够去进行多步的工具调用
那这也就是我们所谓的agent接口的概念好了
那么到这里啊
相信你已经理解了它们之间的区别了
传统rag其实就是固定流程检索一次生成
一次结束了
那agent tic rag它是等于智能体的行为
它是可以去规划调用
反思以及迭代的
理解了这样的区别之后啊
我们接下来就能够去迈向更关键的大模型
应用开发好
接下来的话
我们再来看一下
咱们具体的代码实现的这个部分啊
就他到底是如何去实现这种AGH
提和rap的能力的
那首先的话我们先来讲一下
就是传统rag它是如何去实现的
那整个的流程啊
我们可以参考咱们右边的这张图
也就是我们前面讲过的
离线的这一部分和在线的啊这一部分的内容
那因为代码也比较简单啊
所以我就带着大家快速的去过一遍
那整个内容的话
核心啊我们是通过long chat来实现的
所以大家可以直接参考这一部分代码啊
首先第一步的话
就是我们要去加载咱们的这个文档啊
比如说你有了这个
比如这里我们是一个TXT的一个文件
那大家的话可以把它替换成
你要去处理的文本啊
比如说像这个PDF啊
word啊都是可以的
它也支持啊
然后这个test和loader吧
那么它到底是什么意思呢
其实就是把我们的这个文档
加载到咱们的这个内存里面来
本质上其实就是一个读取文件的操作啊
你可以理解为咱们这个read file好吧
一样的好
那么文档加载完成之后啊
接下来我们对文档来进行切分啊
因为一个完整的文档比较大
所以我们就会用到这个long chain里面的
这个递归分割的这样一个方式啊
那他的逻辑也非常简单
我们只要去设置两个内容
第一个也就是我们每一个文本块的一个大小
比如说你要设置成100个字符
200个字符还是500个字符啊
都是可以的
然后第二个就是文本块之间的一个
重叠的一个部分
那其实就是我们前面有讲到过的啊
这个段落和段落之间啊可重叠的这样一个部分
那有了这两个参数之后啊
那我们就能够拿到对应的这样一个段落了啊
比如说一篇小说啊
这个一章小说
那可能现在就已经被切分成30个段落
那对于每一个段落唉
接下来我们都需要通过一个embedding模型
来进行向量化
那这个embedding模型怎么来的啊
在这里我用的是一个啊
硅基流动的这样的一个服务啊
OK然后模型的话选择的是千万3embedding啊
0.6B的这样一个模型
那接口的话就是用这这个open i的
然后这里面还有个APIK啊
那这是我自己的好吧
当然大家的话也不要用我的
因为没有用啊
录完视频之后
我会把这个K啊去删掉
那么大家的话可以直接去硅基流动啊
自己去申请啊
因为也是免费的啊
他会给你对应的额度
那么向量化完成之后唉
接下来我们就需要把对应的这样一个内容啊
然后存储到咱们的向量数据库当中去啊
那么在这里啊
我们选择的是相对比较简单的这个CHA
那普罗马的话是一个非常简单易用的
这样一个向量数据库啊
那么在这里的话怎么去实现呢
那很简单啊
大家可以看到
其实就是提供我们对应的三个参数
第一个参数啊
是不是LIOR
那这就什么
这就是我们切分之后的这样一个
文本的这样一个片段啊
也就是我们的段落
然后embedding啊
这是我们的embedding模型
那我们前面去设置好的
然后第三个啊也就我们这个干嘛
我们的这个路径啊
看到吗
OK好
那这个路径的话
我们就设置是当前的这样一个路径啊
就你那个绝对啊
我们这边是设置了一个相对的一个路径啊
然后他就去进行一个保存
然后最后啊再来做一个结果的一个打印好
那么代码我们讲解完之后啊
下面简单的来运行一下
看一下它实际的效果有没有问题
偶我们稍微等待一下啊
好那现在我们可以看到啊最终的一个结果了
那么一共的话是把37个文本块啊
全部存到咱们的这个向量数据库当中来了
那么也就是我们的这个TXT啊
这个文件
那一共的话是切分成了37个片段啊
OK好那这就是我们的第一个部分啊
离线的这个部分对吧
我们已经把什么把我们的这个文本数据哎
从文本转换成向量
那接下来的话我们再来看一下在线的这个部分
那么实际上啊它它会比什么
它会比我们这个离线部分会更简单啊
为什么
因为在实际的工作当中啊
大部分的这个我们要去处理的内容
其实都在离线链路
大家想一下
如果说你是一个大模型的这个开发人员
这个应用跟你啊其实是没什么太大的关系的
好吧
我们需要去做的就是
如何去给模型提供更好的上下文啊
让模型的回答能做得更好
所以它的重点在于如何去切分文档
切分的方式有很多对吧
怎么去选择以及如何去做向量化的存储对吧
我们可以去选择或者说微调自己的这个模型
甚至说决定啊
是否要使用咱们这个query的一个改写的
这样一些策略
那这样的一些内容他都能够去影响
最终我们拼接到这个prompt提示词里面的
这个啊context它的一个质量
所以最重要的工作其实都已经在离线链路里面
我们其实已经把它做好了
所以在这个在线链路里面
那么我们其实去看的话
它的这几部分内容
首先第一个部分还是一样的对吧
也是去加载咱们的一个embedding模型啊
这个是没有任何的一个区别好
然后这个地方有一个wor strong
那么这个呢就是加载咱们的cha dB啊
把咱们的这个向量数据库
你给它加载进来
加载进来之后
接下来我们去构造了一个用户提问的这样一个
query啊
因为我这个是一本小说啊
所以就随便提了一个问题
就是韩立啊
比如他的这个二哥啊叫什么名字
OK好
那么有了这个query之后
然后我们来开始来进行检索
检索在这里啊也是非常简单了
直接去调用咱们这个similarity啊
然后设计的这样一个方法
然后把我们这个query啊
用户的问题传进来
然后这边有个K等于三
那么表示返回最相关的三个片段就OK了
所以我们的这个DOS啊
那么它的一个结果其实就是三个document啊
这样的一个文档
然后拿到这个文档之后
我们在干嘛
诶我们在这里做了一个内容的一个读取
看到了吗
哎这边有个配置content
就是把它里面具体的文本内容啊读取出来
然后我们把这个context拼接到咱们的这个提示词
模板里面来了
O好
那么给到这个题词模板之后
接下来创建咱们的大语言模型
然后把咱们这个提示词再给到这个模型
让它去生成最终的这样一个答案啊
就可以了啊
所以这个地方咱们这个提词
这个模板其实也比较简单啊对吧
就是如果说你知道
那你就回答对吧
如果说你不知道
那你也不要这个胡编乱造
所以在接下来的话
我们就来运行一下啊
OK好这边会有很多的一些提示啊
这个我们可以直接忽略啊
因为这个没有影响
好来我们看一下
那么首先的话是我们的一个参考的一个文档好
那么参考文档有三条片段
这是第一条
然后第二条对吧
OKOK还有这一条啊
三条好
然后这三条文档的话
我们大家可以看到
其实都是和这个大哥相关的啊
没有去体现出来这个二哥的一个内容
所以用户的这个问题
那么最终的一个大模型的一个回答
给到的是什么
不知道啊
因为参考文档里面没有提到这个啊
这个二哥是谁
所以其实我们可以发现啊
对于我们真正的这样一套rag系统来讲
最核心的其实就在于咱们的这个context的上下文
就如何去构
如何去给他去构造这个啊
高质量的这个contest
才是我们的一个工作的一个重点啊
好所以说我们要跟大家去分享的
就是我们传统rap的这样一个实现的
这样一个方式啊
OK那么我们在讲完了传统rag的实现之后啊
接下来我们再来看一下agency和rag
那么它到底是如何去实现的
如果我们在工作当中啊
也想要去做一套agent tic rag这样一套系统
具体啊该怎么去做啊
那么大家的话其实可以去参考啊切的box啊
这个软件啊
它是怎么去实现的
因为它是开源的
所以在GITHUB上面也能找到它对应的源代码
它里面其实就实现了这样一套系统啊
传统的rag都是检索拼接
然后到生成一条龙
直接去输出对应的结果
而agent tic rag
那么它是一个agent的循环的一个过程
好吧
从思考到行动观察
然后再思考得出结论
他是一个多步的一个过程啊
他是一个不断去循环的一个过程
那如果你对思考与行动模式啊
还不太了解的同学
可以去看我之前的这一期视频
那里面的话详细的去讲解了react agent
它实现的全部流程
下面的话我们再来看一下啊
那么cheat box啊
他的一个实现的一个逻辑啊
那么在这里的话有一张图啊
给大家来看一下啊
那么在这张图片当中啊
呃其实就很好的去体现了
为什么china box啊
它在早期啊就体现了比其他产品
那就更强的这个edittic red的这样一个能力啊
那么它整体的实现它怎么去做的
它是用时间啊去换取了模型的这样一个智能
当用户把问题发过来之后啊
系统首先需要去判断
那么我们的模型它是否支持工具的调用
那如果说不支持
那不支持的话
我们就不用去看左边了啊
直接去看右边就可以了
那么在右边的话
我们就通过这个prompter去判断咱们这个问题啊
是否需要进行检索来进
需要检索才能够回答
那如果说我们判断出来不需要
那不需要的话
我们就可以直接去进行回复了
也就直接就跳到这里好吧
那我们这个系统啊
直接就给到用户的这样一个回答啊
没有去进行这样一个啊片段的一个检索
那这种方式它比我们在prompt里面
让模型去忽略无关的这个context的更优啊好吧
或者它的效果会更好
因为我们是用两个模型来做的决策
理论上它的效果就会更好
那如果说我们判断出来的结果是需要干嘛呢
诶是需要来进行检索
那么在这里哎
我们就会先来到咱们的这个知识库当中啊
去进行这样一个语义的一个搜索
搜索完了之后得到相关的这个文档的片段
然后再把这个相关的片段去
注入到咱们的这个context啊
咱们的这个上下文里面来
然后再基于这样一个结果啊
去生成对应的这样一个回答
好这是我们的第一种情况
就是这个模型它不支持工具调用
那么如果说模型它支持工具调用
那怎么办呢
那这个时候我们会直接把我们的这样一个工具
的这样一个集合唉
全部注册到咱们这个模型里面来
然后让我们的模型啊自主决策
去调用哪一些工具
比如说检索的工具对吧
OK好有这个语义检索的工具
然后还有咱们这个文件列表的工具啊对吧
或者读取某一个文件
具体的这个内容的这个工具啊
非常非常多
我们再把所有的这个决策啊
交给咱们的这个模型啊
而不是说啊固定一步啊
要检索到这个结果啊
那这就是AGH集合啊
好吧
就他能够更早的去利用模型的能力啊
去提升rap的效果
因为在传统的rap当中
我们只有在生存阶段才会用到咱们的大模型
但是在agent tic rag当中啊
我们从判断开始啊
从我们这个用户输入问题之后啊
我们就会开始去用咱们的大模型来进行决策
好吧
那么对于这样这样的一些工具来讲啊
比如这边有四个对吧
好如果啊我们在实际的应用当中啊
那你觉得除了这个search query之外
因为这个是我们最基本的一个工具啊
除了这个基本的之外
如果你觉得不够啊
那么我们还能够去设计一些辅助的一些工具
比如说这三个那chat box里面啊
其实就有这么几个啊
比较有特色的工具
那第一个的话就是这个list files
那么他的一个作用的话就是能够去列出来
比如什么能够去列出来啊
当前这个知识库里面的文件清单啊
他能够去作为一个兜底
为什么呢
因为传统的red他是无法去回答你
比如说你的知识库里面有哪一些文档
这个他能回答吗
不能因为传统rap的本质他是去做什么
他是把这个检索到一部分内容之后啊
然后交给大模型来进行回答
但是它的这个内容肯定是不完整的好吧
所以你问他有哪些文档
他肯定回答不了
但是有了这样的一个工具之后
我们就能够让模型来进行调用啊
并且得到当前的这个知识库
里面有多少个文件啊
它数量的这样一些信息都能够获取到啊
这是第一个
然后第二个还有一个是这个read file check啊
那么这个方法它的这个作用是什么呢
就它能够按照我们的这个呃
根据我们这个文档的这个id啊
然后精确的来进行这样一个片段的一个读取啊
那么好处的话有两个
第一个就是它能够规定啊
你只读这个特定的这样一个文本片段
好吧
就我把这个id告诉你
你就读这个就可以了
然后第二个当他发现这个信息不完整的时候
他可以主动啊去读取这个前后的这样一个check
去补充咱们这个上下文
那么这样的话
我们就不需要去依赖咱们的语义的相似度检索
我们直接通过固定的这个id
然后去获取到相邻的这个上下文
那除此之外之外
还有一些
比如说这个啊
get film matter这样一个原读取这个原数据的啊
好吧
当然这个我们用的比较少
所以这样的一些方法或者这样的一些工具啊
就是前的boss啊
他的这样一个实现的一个方式啊
好吧
所以我们在传统rap当中对吧
可能我们检索不到信息的时候
哎我们就直接返回说没有找到了
但是在agency和react当中啊
他可能会尝试啊去改写我们的这个query啊
这样的一个问题
然后再去检索啊
或者说用这个啊read for your chunk
然后去补充咱们上下文
然后再做最终的一个回复啊
那么在这里话大家的话也可以看一下啊
我们下面的这两个案例啊
能够让大家更精准的去理解啊
这个agent t和rag它到底是什么意思啊
OK好
那么在这两个案例当中
首先第一个对吧
传统rag就是用户的查询
然后向量检索
然后检索到结果之后啊
然后再生成对应最终的一个答案
那agent tic rag他怎么去做呢
首先它会有第一轮搜索
第一轮搜索
那么我们就用传统的这个什么这个query search啊
来进行这样一个搜索好
然后搜索完成之后
那么结果它可能不是很好
那我们就能够观察到命中率啊
非常的低
所以我们就要去尝试去改写
咱们的这一个查询的这样一个词好
然后第二步搜索的时候
已经改写过了
然后再去进行查找
那我们就能够命中一些比较相关的
这样的一些check
然后再进行第三轮的搜索哎
去获取一些这个相关的这样的一些文档
然后最后啊再基于我们这个比较干嘛
就比较这个已经整理好的一些步骤啊
然后去完成整个片段的这样的一个回复啊
那这就是他们两个之间啊最大的一个区别
那下面的话我们也可以来看一下啊
它的一个源代码其实也比较简单啊
我们可以来看一下
那么这四个工具啊
它分别指的是什么
好吧
比如说第一个啊
这个代码的话再做一点啊
我也给大家来我们看一下啊
好那么方法的话其实就具体的话就在这里啊
四个核心工具啊
比如第一个就我们比较基础的啊
query search好吧
然后这个get fail
然后这个read fail
然后以及咱们这个list fail
好吧好
那么这四个工具啊分别是做什么的
那我们其实刚才已经讲过了啊
那么对于这点
我们是怎么去实现这个edgetic rap的
这样一套系统的呢
那其实我们是用到了这个create啊
然后react agent啊
那么这是哪一个呢
这是在呃long graph里面的一个包啊
好吧
用long graph里面的这个包啊去实现这个htc rag啊
有这个什么嘞
他有这样一个观察与思考的这样一个模式啊
好那么他的这个实现的方式啊也比较简单啊
就是我们前面哎
是不是已经定义好了这四个工具了好吧
当然你也可以只有一个工具啊好吧
哪怕你只有一个query search好吧
那也算啊
OK那我们接下来有了这个工具之后啊
接下来我们就要去写一段提示词啊
就我们要去引导咱们的这个大模型啊
怎么去使用这样一个工具
那比如说你是一个agent tic rag的一个助手对吧
然后你要巴拉巴拉对吧
第一步干嘛
第二步干嘛
第三步干嘛等等啊
非常非常多的这样一些内容好吧
当然这方实际上我们在使用的时候要注意啊
就是他的这样一个回复啊
一定要进行限制
为什么
因为如果说你不进行限制的话
它很多时候他会把一些符号把它去掉
比如这个引号啊
或者括号它就把它去掉
那去掉之后我们这个调用啊就会失败啊
OK好
然后接下来我们来看一下
那么这个create
然后react agent
那么这个它到底需要哪些参数
首先第一个就是咱们的大模型啊
那这个就跟前面是一样的啊
做了一个模型的一个初始化
然后接下来第二个有一个工具的一个列表
那这个工具列表来我们看一下
在这里我们是做了一个注册的啊
一共的话是有四个工具
然后第三个部分就是一个system prompter
哎咱们的一个系统提示词
那么有了这三个参数之后
我们就能够实现这样的一个A镜头好吧
那创建好这个agent的之后啊
接下来我们就可以直接去运行了
那运行的话更简单啊
直接直接去调用它的这个in work啊
然后把我们的这个消息啊传进去啊
就OK了好吧
这个代码看上去简单
但是它却能够让模型完成自主决策啊
动态调整的这个能力啊
所以下面的话也可以给它运行一下啊
当然因为他这个原始的数据啊
是这个去模拟的啊
并不是真实的
所以说我们就看一下它实际啊
执行的一个效果啊
就OK了啊
好首先的话是初始化啊
然后这个地方我们包含的一些文件啊
分别有哪一些文件
然后它里面有几个chunk啊
这个这个模拟的一个知识库啊
然后下面的话就开始去做这个问答
比如说问题是什么对吧
基于知识库
然后去概述它的一些优缺点
然后给出一些引用啊
好然后这是咱们最后啊返回的一个结果啊
那这个结果就包含了我们对应的这样
一个文档啊
以及它相关的这样一些片段啊
这个就是我们想要的这样一个内容啊
看到没有
read file check啊
那么到这里啊
我们这个源代码就给大家讲完了啊
好吧
其实就这么一坨
大家千万不要觉得对吧
chat box啊
作为企业级产品
然后它背后的技术是不是很复杂
其实关键的逻辑啊就这么简单好吧
他只是会考虑很多的一些边界的一些情况
所以在这里大家能够看到这一部分内容
其实是把这个核心的部分给它抽取出来了
所以大家你学这个agent tic rag啊
其实你看这一段代码基本上就能够去实现了
所以我们其实国内啊
很多的一些套壳的一些应用啊
其实啊都是这么去实现的
把一些核心的一部分把它抽出来
好吧好了
那么到这里的话
本期视频的话就结束了啊
下面的话简单给大家去总结一下啊
那首先的话我们是回顾了啊传统rag
那么它的一个实现的一个逻辑啊
不知道大家还有没有印象好吧
它其实是两个固定的流程
第一个就是我们的文档切片
然后向量化再到存储
然后第二个部分的话就是向量检索啊
然后再拼接我们的PROMETER
然后大模型去生成答案
那这种方式的话简单直接但缺乏灵活性啊
没有办法去应对啊
检索失败啊
或者说信息不完整的情况
然后的话我们重点给大家去讲了
这个agency和reg
那么它的这样一个核心的这样一个思想啊
就是把检索文件读取啊
这样的一些能力封装成可以去调用的工具啊
赋予大模型自主决策的这样一个权利
模型可以根据任务的需求
动态的去规划行动
调用工具
观察结果
并进行多轮迭代
直到获得足够的信息啊
生成最终的答案
那么这个过程真正的去体现了智能体的行为啊
从思考行动观察
然后再思考
那么为了去加深理解的话
那我也给大家去拆解了咱们开源项目啊
切的box的这样一个实现
那么它就是通过啊去设计了什么
比如说像咱们刚刚有讲到这个啊list files啊对吧
read files这样的一些特色的一些工具啊
那不仅能够去支持我们基础的检索
那么还能够去回答精确读取啊
并且补充上下文的这样一个能力
那最后的话我们再通过代码给他去演示
两种rag的实现差异
那么传统rag代码简洁
但流程是固化的
而agent tic rag
虽然说核心的逻辑啊同样是简洁的
因为我们是借助于啊
long graph这样的一个框架去实现的
但是他却能够去用去干嘛
诶去把这个模型的自主能力啊释放出来
能够实现动态灵活的交互
所以工具赋予能力
而智能在于选择真正的agent tic rag啊
始于检索
沉于决策
我是海文
我们下期再见